Jamie Diamond is the CEO of JP Morgan
the largest bank in the United States of
America and he just went absolutely off
on the Biden Administration oil and gas
industry and what he perceives as the
nonsense ESG market during a private
Investor's Summit for JP Morgan clients
Jamie Diamond stated the president of
the United States needs to stand up and
say we may not meet our 2050 climate
objectives because this is a [__] War
he then said it's time to stop going hat
in hand to Venezuela and Saudi and we
should start pumping more oil and gas in
the USA and then lastly when asked about
ESG he said investors don't give a [__]
and he warns not to see governance to do
gooder kids on a committee it's not very
often that we get it here the unfiltered
thoughts of the CEO of America's largest
bank